we try to hire really smart people but
we have a very simple organization and
we try to focus and do very few things
well and focusing is hard because
focusing doesn't mean saying yes it
means saying no so we say we decide not
to do a lot of things so we can focus on
a few handfuls of things and do them
well when you first got the job as CEO
you got a call from Steve Jobs and he
offered you some advice long story short
he said hey congratulations it's great
you're gonna do a great job I said we'll
do you have any advice and he said no no
you're great and then there's a pause
and it goes well I do have some advice
he goes Nike makes some of the best
product in the world
I mean product that you lust after
absolutely beautiful stunning product
but you also make a lot of crap he said
just get rid of the crappy stuff and
focus on the good stuff and then I
expected a little pause and a laugh but
there was there was a pause but no laugh
at the end and he was absolutely right
you just watched two amazing clips and
Steve Jobs take the next three minutes
to sit quietly and think about how you
can apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]